the easiest way for any leader to
explain why they do what they do and you
you can all do this this is the easiest
way to to explain your drive and your
why and how you can create love and
inspiration around you and build a
following think of something that has
happened to you or that you've done in
your career that you absolutely loved
being a part of I mean loved it doesn't
matter if it it was it was successful it
doesn't matter if it got you recognition
or promotion it doesn't matter but
something that happened that you like if
every day of my career could be like
this one be the happiest person alive if
you can tell that story in other words
you speak to that emotional part of the
brain by telling a story when when you
when you sit down with people say let me
tell you why I love this organization
let me tell you why we do what we do I'm
trying to communicate how I feel and my
perspective on the World by telling you
stories I'm using stories to capture the
essence of what I mean right um and you
can do the same thing the more stories
you tell the more personal they are the
more powerful they become it also allows
people to humanize the job which is
really what it's all about and I think
that's the disc disc needs to happen
like if you can understand the context
you can
debate the what they're doing and how
they're doing it and that's changeable
and you can absolutely push back on that
but you have to understand why it's
happening at the first place which is
always something deeply emotional and
deeply human and the kind of
organization you're trying to build the
kind of organization you uh the kind of
values you want your people to adhere to
so the easiest way to do it is to is to
tell your own stories and and and and
you know you have a good story when you
start with let me tell you what I love
about this organization let me tell you
story that captures what I love about
what we're doing and why we're here like
if you can use the word love your story
will immediately go in the right
direction